an object whose
Parallax is one AR
second is at a distance of one
parseek what that's where we get the
distance parseek from look at that so
you've heard parek used in Star
Trek movie ever and our boy in in Star
Wars did the kessle run in 12 parex
right which is profoundly ignorant of
what a parseek is right because a parsec
is a unit of distance it's not a unit of
time time and then the apologist got
online said here dror Tyson here's why
he says Parx and it made up some total
BS about it was a dist he found a loop
that was shorter and that's why he did
it in 12 Parx instead of 15 par so they
and I said all right I I'm staying away
from this community of fans because Star
Wars is
Magic